let me draw a function that would be
interesting to take a limit of and I'll
just draw it visually for now and then
we'll do some specific examples a little
later so that's my y-axis and that's my
x-axis and let's say the function looks
something like I don't make it a fairly
straightforward function let's say it's
it's a line for the most part let's say
it looks just like that except it has a
hole at some point X is equal to a so
it's undefined there let me black that
point out just so you can see that it's
not defined there and that point there
is X is equal to a this is the x axis
this is the y is equal to f of x axis
let's say just say that's the y axis and
let's say this is the this is f of X or
this is y is equal to f of X now we've
done a bunch of videos on limits I think
you have an intuition on this if I were
to say what is the limit as X approaches
a and let's say that this point right
here this point right here is L we know
from our previous videos that well first
of all I could write it down let's see
the limit as X approaches a of f of X
what this means intuitively is as we get
as we approach a from either side right
as we approach it from that side what
does f of X approach right so as when X
is here f of X is here is right there
when X is here f of X is there and as we
see we see that it's approaching this L
right there right when you approach from
that side and then when we approach a
from that side right and we've done
limits where you approach from only the
left or right side but actually have a
limit it has to approach the same thing
from the pause on the positive direction
and the negative direction but you go
from there if you pick this X then this
is f of X f of X is right there if X
gets here then it goes here and as we
see as we get closer and closer to a f
of X approaches this point L right or
this value L so we say that the limit of
f of X as X approaches a is equal to L
and I think we have that intuition but
this was not a very it's actually not
rigorous at all in terms
being specific in terms what we mean is
a limit you know all I've said so far is
we get X gets closer what does f of X
get closer to so in this video we will
attempt to explain to you a definition
of a limit that has a little bit more or
actually a lot more mathematical rigor
than just saying you know as X gets
closer to this value what does f of X
get closer to and and the way I think
about it's kind of like a little game
the definition is so if this this means
this statement right here means that if
you wanna that I can always give you a
range about this point I can always give
you a range and when I talk about range
I'm not talking about it in the whole
domain range aspect I'm just talking
about a range like a you know as long as
I'm no further than I can I can give you
a distance from a as long as I'm no
further than that I can guarantee you I
can guarantee you that your that f of X
is going not going to be any further
than a given distance from L and the way
I think about it is it could be viewed
as a little game let's say you say okay
Sal I don't believe you I want to I want
to see you know whether f of X can get
within 0.5 of L right so you want so
let's say you give me point five you
give me point five and you say Sal I
want you know by this definition you
should always be able to give me a range
around a that'll get me within that'll
get f of X within point five of al right
so F of it the values of f of X are
always going to be right in this range
right there and as long as I'm in that
range around a as long as I'm the range
around you give me f of X will always be
at least that close to our limit point f
of X will always be at least that closed
sign let me let me draw it a little bit
bigger just because I think it's it's
I'm just overwriting the same diagram
over and over again so let's say that
this is f of X this is the whole point
right and the dirt doesn't have to be a
hole there the limit could equal
accurate value of the function but it's
the limits more interesting when the
function isn't defined there what the
limit is so this point right here
that is let me draw the axes again let
me draw so that's x axis y axis x y this
is the limit point L this is the point a
so the definition of the limit and I'll
go back to this in a second because now
that is bigger I want to explain it
again it says this this means and this
is the epsilon-delta definition of
limits and we'll touch on epsilon and
Delta in a second is I can guarantee you
that f of X will you give me any
distance from L you want right and
actually let's call that epsilon and
let's just hit on the the definition
right from the get-go so you say I want
to be no more than epsilon away from L +
Epsilon can just be any number greater
any real number greater than zero so
that would be this distance right here
is Epsilon
this distance there is Epsilon right and
for any epsilon you give me any real
number so this is this is you know this
would be L plus epsilon right here this
would be L minus epsilon right here the
epsilon Delta definition of the of of
this says that no matter what epsilon
you give me I can always specify a
distance around a and I'll call that
Delta I can always specify a distance
around a so let's say this is a this is
Delta less than a and this is Delta more
than a this is the letter Delta and this
is Delta more than a where as long as
you pick an X that's within a plus Delta
and a minus Delta as long as the X is
within here I can guarantee you that the
f of X the corresponding f of X is going
to be within your range and if you think
about it this makes sense right it's
essentially saying I can get you as
close as you want to this limit point
just by you know and when I say as close
as you want you define what you want by
giving me an epsilon it's a little bit
of a game and I can get you as close as
you want to that
limit point by giving you a range around
the point that X is approaching and as
long as you pick an x value that's
within this within this range around a
as long as you pick an x value around
there I can guarantee you that f of X
will be within the range you specify and
so you know just to make this a little
bit more concrete you could give me
let's say you say I want f of X to be
within point 5 let's just make
everything concrete numbers let's say
this is the number two and this is let's
say this is number one right so we're
saying that the limit as X approaches 1
of f of X I haven't defined f of X but
it looks like a line with the hole right
there is equal to two this means that
you could give me any any number let's
say let's say you want to try it out for
a couple of examples let's say you say I
want f of X to be within point let me do
a different color I want f of X to be
within point five of two right so this
would you know I want f of X to be
between two point five and one point
five then I could say ok as long as you
pick an X that's within I don't know I
could you know it could be arbitrarily
close but as long as you pick an X
that's let's say it works for this
function that's between I don't know Oh
point nine and one point one right so in
this case the Delta from our limit point
is only 0.1 as long as you pick an X
dispute that within point one of this
point or one I can guarantee you I can
guarantee you that your f of X is going
to lie in that range and let me
so hopefully you get a little bit sense
of that let me define that with the
actual epsilon Delta and this is what
you'll actually see in your math
textbook and then we'll do a couple of
examples and and just to be clear that
was just a specific example you gave me
one epsilon and I gave you a delta that
worked but in order for this that by
definition the definition of the epsilon
def if this is true or someone rises
they're saying it doesn't just work for
one specific entrance one specific
instance it works for any number you
give me you can say I want to be within
one millionth of a you know one to the
or 10 to the negative hundredth power of
two you know super close to two and I
can
always give you a range around this
point where as long as you pick an x in
that range f of X will always be within
this range that you specify within that
you know one trillionth of a of a unit
away from away from the limit point and
of course and the one thing I can't
guarantee you is what happens when X is
equal to a I'm just saying you can get
as long as you pick an X that's within
my range but not on a it'll work your f
of X will show up to be within the range
you specify and just to make the math
clear because I've been speaking only in
word so far and this is what you see in
the textbook it says look you give me
any epsilon so give me any epsilon
greater than zero anyway this is a
definition right if someone writes this
they mean that you can give them any
epsilon greater than zero and then
they'll give you a delta they'll give a
delta all right and remember your
epsilon is how close you want f of X to
be to your limit point right it's a
range around f of X they'll give you a
delta which is a range around around a
right let me write this so limit as X
approaches a of f of X is equal to L so
they'll give you a delta where as long
as X is no more than Delta of so as long
as you know we so the distance between X
and a right so if we pick an X here let
me do another color if we pick an X here
the distance between that value in a as
long as one that's greater than zero so
that X doesn't show up on top of a right
because the function might be undefined
at that point but as long as the
distance between X and ay is greater
than zero and less than this X range
that they gave you it's less than Delta
so as long as you take an X you know if
I if I were to zoom the x-axis right
here this is a and so this would right
here would be this distance right here
would be Delta and this distance right
here would be Delta as long as you pick
an x value that falls here so there's
only to pick that x value or this x
value or this
x value as long as you pick one of those
X values I can guarantee you that the
distance between your function and the
limit point so the distance between you
know when you take one of these X values
and you evaluate f of X at that point
that the distance between that f of X
and the limit point is going to be less
than the number you gave them right and
if you think you know it's almost it
seems very complicated and I have mixed
feelings about where this is included in
most calculus curriculums it's included
in like that you know the third week
before you even learn derivatives and
it's kind of this very math e and
rigorous thing to think about and you
know it tends to derail a lot of
students and a lot of people I don't
think get a lot of the intuition behind
it but if this is a you know it is
mathematically rigorous I think it is
very valuable once you actually study
you know more advanced calculus or we
become a math major but with that said
this does make a lot of sense
intuitively right because before we were
talking about look you know I can get
you as close as X approaches this value
f of X is going to as X approaches this
value f of X is going to approach this
value and the way we mathematically
define it is you say Sal I want to be
super close I want the distance to be f
of X and L you know I want to be point 1
then I can always give you a distance
around X where this will be true and I'm
all out of time in the vit next this
video in the next video I'll do some
examples where I prove the limits where
I prove some limit statements using this
definition and hopefully you know when
we use some tangible numbers you'll
you'll this definition will make a
little bit more sense see in the next
video